Support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft.com/people ready.
I'm Alice Rivlin and I'm a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution.
There are some quite obvious things that
companies can do a right now,
depending on what kind of companies they
are.
A,
if we're fixing our crumbling
infrastructure,
uh,
then,
companies that specialize in doing that,
uh,
will benefit if we're giving more people
access to broadband,
uh,
that is,
certainly,
uh,
an opportunity if we're making our
healthcare system more efficient.
There will be some people who will lose
by that,
uh,
but there will also be both,
providers and uh,
uh,
the,
healthcare,
uh,
technology industry that will benefit
the stimulus plan is,
I think,
widely misunderstood because people
think of it as just infrastructure.
It is partly that,
but,
uh,
the most important part of the stimulus
I thought were the parks that got money
to individuals so that they could keep
paying their bills.
Uh,
that means the food stamp part of the
unemployment benefits,
uh,
increase,
the modest increase in social security
benefits and the other part that seemed
to me very important were the benefits
to states to keep them from cutting back
on their services.
So,
uh,
and I didn't even mention the tax cuts
which go to ordinary people and those
things will keep demand up.
It will keep a consumption up and it'll
benefit the businesses across the board.
There's no special benefit here.
It just means that people will not be
cutting back on their consumption as
much as they ordinarily would have.
We were bringing a lot of talent to Wall
Street that in my opinion would have
been better employed doing something
else.
The financial services industry got way
out of kilter with the rest of the
economy.
Financial services are supposed to be
serving the rest of the economy.
Actually,
our services industry got into a
position where it was largely servicing
itself.
We don't need that many smart people
inventing more and more complex
derivatives and instruments to sell to
each other.
Uh,
there is very little social benefit in
that activity.
Now,
I don't mean we can close down all the
derivatives markets or anything like
that,
uh,
but,
if compensation in financial services is
less astronomical and we attract less of
our high,
a high skilled talent into financial
services and more of it into other parts
of the economy,
it'll be all to the good.
This massive disaster,
uh,
has certainly exposed weaknesses in the
financial sector.
Uh,
some we knew were there,
many we didn't,
and we need a drastic overhaul,
I think on two fronts.
Partly it is a question of modernizing
our regulatory system,
which simply did not keep up with the
advances in financial innovation and
globalization that were happening all
around us.
That means a stricter regulation for
major institutions that are very
interlinked with the rest of the
economy.
And indeed with the global economy,
they can't be too strict.
We need those major institutions.
The second front,
which I think is more important,
is we need to go over our economic
structure or economic architecture and
look for perverse incentives.
Places where there are incentives that a
meaning that people can make a lot of
money doing something really risky.
Now we had a good example of that in
mortgage lending,
mortgage lending standards got very lax
in part because we missed a perverse
incentive.
We missed the fact that the loan
originator has no reason to worry about
the credit worthiness of the borrower.
If he doesn't keep any of that risk
himself.
If he's just a selling this,
a mortgage to somebody else as part of a
package backing a bond issue,
then he has no reason to worry about
whether the borrower can repay.
That was a perverse incentive.
It had been there for awhile,
but nobody noticed it.
It was the big influx of capital into
the mortgage backed security market.
Lot of it coming from that exposed this
weakness and we have to look for things
like that and change them.
I think that President Obama has to work
right now on the thing that is most
important,
namely getting out of this recession and
getting the financial services industry
functioning again.
If he doesn't accomplish that,
and I think he will,
it will be a disaster for business.
Uh,
we need a functioning economy where
people have jobs.
We need to be a more sustainable economy
than we were before,
both in an environmental sense and um,
in the sense that we need to save more
and finance more of our own investment
out of domestic saving.
I think that will happen because people
who borrowed too much and consumed too
much got badly burned.
But we need an economy which is
functioning well and in which people are
saving more,
borrowing less and uh,
doing more productive
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
Microsoft.com/people ready.